la parole est maintenant à à notre
collègue roger karoutchi pour le groupe
l'est républicain vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur la sphère des
migrants pose en réalité trois problèmes
un problème humanitaire on va pas
revenir dessus c'est clair que ce qui se
passe en méditerranée et inacceptable la
mort la souffrance le débarquement dans
des conditions invraisemblables en
italie est un sujet qui se pose à tous
et pas seulement aux italiens le second
problème est un problème matériel et
financier sans revenir sur les chiffres
de la cour des comptes qui dit le droit
d'asile immigration clandestine tout
cela représente à peu près deux
milliards que ce soit l'aide médicale
d'état
l'hébergement la location la durée de
l'étude de chaque dossier de demandeur
d'asile un chiffre de milliards qui en
réalité entre le droit d'asile
les déboutés du droit d'asile et
l'immigration clandestine est un chiffre
probable a certifié probable et c'est un
chiffre qui interpelle dans un moment où
nous sommes tous contraints
financièrement matériellement le
troisième problème est un problème de
rupture de société un certain nombre de
responsables et pas seulement de droite
disent que nous sommes et que nous
atteignons un point de rupture dans la
société
le point de rupture il est dans
l'acceptation difficiles on voit ce qui
vient de se passer entre les crs et
certains migrants à calais on a vu ce
qui s'est passé à paris on voit les
propositions des uns ou des autres sur
la création de centres mais en même
temps personne ne s'y retrouve et nous
avons le sentiment que l'europe balbutie
ce qui s'est passé à luxembourg ne nous
rassure pas on a le sentiment monsieur
le ministre vous personnellement vous
dites oui il faut des position de
fermeté mais que nous avons en parallèle
un cadre européen qui ne s'y prête pas
qui ne prend pas les bonnes décisions
rapides par rapport à ce qui se passe en
méditerranée que nous avons en france un
système qui en réalité n'a plus la
capacité financière de suivre on intègre
mal ce qu'ils obtiennent le droit
d'asile et on traite finalement
massivement et en quantité ceux qui sont
déboutés
et qui ne sont pas accompagnés aux
frontières alors aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre la question est simple il ya
une pression considérable sur les
frontières du sud avec l'italie sur les
frontières en général il ya un point
d'acceptation dans la société française
qui est dépassé il ya une vision de ce
qui est en train de se passer et la
notion d' éventuellement 300000
personnes supplémentaires dix dans
l'année qui vient
qu'est ce que concrètement veut faire le
gouvernement français on a vu je termine
juste là votre plan d'hier sur un
meilleur accueil
il ya déjà un certain nombre de mesures
qui étaient prévues nous sommes monsieur
le ministre
pardon de vous le dire loin du compte
par rapport à la pression qui est à nos
frontières
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement a
la responsabilité de la sécurité
intérieure et la responsabilité de
l'unité de la nation
comment comptez vous procéder pour vous
répondre la parole et à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez la parole oui bien sûr je n'ai
aucun problème extrêmement grave qui moi
m'interdit les commentaires puisque je
suis en situation de responsabilité
j'entends beaucoup de commentaires y
compris par de la part de ceux qui ont
par le passé exercé des responsabilités
et moi je vois la gravité de la
situation
je pense que chaque parole sur ce sujet
doit être une parole peser et
responsable et nous devons trouver les
solutions les plus pertinentes d'abord
il ya un problème international pourrait
dire tout ce que vous voulez sur le
niveau d'acceptation en europe il ya une
réalité qui est celle d'hommes et de
femmes qui sont jetés sur les chemins de
l'exode par les persécutions les
exactions et des régimes sanguinaires
mais également par les actes des groupes
terroristes très bien faut-il que
l'europe assure l'accueil de ceux qui
relèvent du statut de réfugié la réponse
du gouvernement est clairement oui
les cinq pays qui accueille 75 % de ces
réfugiés peuvent-ils continuer à le
faire tout seul
l'arrêt sont la réponse est clairement
non c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons proposé un dispositif de
solidarité
les propositions qui ont été exprimées
par l'union européenne ont été inspirées
par nous mêmes car le 30 août dernier
nous demander ce que nous faisons je
vous l'expliquais j'ai procédé une
tournée des capitales européennes en
proposant à tous mes homologues
istres de l'intérieur d'accepter un
dispositif dans lequel il y ait
davantage de solidarité mais aussi
davantage de responsabilités c'est quoi
la responsabilité la responsabilité
c'est trois choses d'abord il faut que
les migrants soient enregistrés dans le
premier pays deux premières arrivées
pour qu'on distingue ce qui relève du
statut de réfugié de ce qui relève de
l'immigration économique irrégulière
deuxième point il faut que ce qui relève
de l'immigration économique irrégulière
soient reconduits vers les pays de
provenance est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons obtenu le triplement des
moyens de frontex et la substitution une
opération exclusivement humanitaire
d'une opération humanitaire mais
également de contrôle des frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne il
faut travailler avec les pays provenance
du monde et placement il ya trois
semaines au niger pour qu'il y ait de
véritable sens de réadmission et de
maintien dans la bande sahélienne de
populations auxquels nous devons
apporter des projets de développement en
france nous faisons deux choses un des
dispositifs d'hébergement renforcé plus
de place pour les réfugiés qui sont dans
les cada les rues ou les centres
d'hébergement d'urgence parce qu'ils
doivent rentrer dans le droit commun du
logement avec des dispositifs
d'insertion
deuxièmement des centres d'hébergement
d'urgence et troisièmement des places en
cada et nous mettons davantage de
fermeté dans les dispositifs de
reconduite à la frontière
nous avons éloigné l'an dernier 15
photos couleur c'est beaucoup plus que
ce qui avait été fait auparavant et nous
continuerons avec cette politique de
fermeté de responsabilité et d'humanité
merci monsieur le ministre